major ukrainian cities are surrounded
and under constant attack
this is chelnive a city of textile
factories churches and monasteries its
greatest misfortune to lie on the route
of russia's advance from the north
in the eastern city of kharkiv too
people wake daily to scenes of terrible
destruction and a fast rising civilian
death toll
look what putin is doing
this is a war crime committed against
the civilians against
the city of kharkiv
this city of one and a half million
people most ethnic russians is being
torn apart by russian forces for no
reason other than that it exists just
across the border from russia in ukraine
and in the far south ukraine's biggest
port odessa is under threat too
[Applause]
here frantic efforts have been underway
for days to build defenses against a
possible beach landing
multiple vessels belonging to russia's
black sea fleet hover on the horizon
including landing ships and support
craft ukraine's military is very much
still in this fight reinforced by
supplies of weapons from abroad
they've been able to apply real pressure
to the russian advance slowing the
progress of a vast column of armor
artillery and soldiers heading for the
capital kiev
along its route once sleepy commuter
towns lie in ruins a foretaste of what
may be in store for kiev the apparent
aim to encircle the city and besiege it
from his bunker under heavy guard
president vladimir zelensky wages a
relentless communications campaign
rallying resistance and calling in
foreign support
we have been saying this for a long time
that ukraine is seeking for protections
for our home soil and our own people but
such protections have not been provided
european countries assisted us with the
waves of migration however we should
discuss the guarantees that are required
to protect our country our home soil and
our people
a second round of talks on thursday
between russia and ukraine at a location
on the border with belarus came with low
expectations of a breakthrough but a
slim glimmer of hope that they're taking
place at all
[Music]
the ukrainian government meanwhile has
called for humanitarian corridors to be
set up and here in the western city of
olive volunteers are hard at work
processing aid donations medicines
clothes food and other essentials for
distribution across the country
there is a humanitarian crisis erupting
on multiple fronts not just the
internally displaced you've left
everything behind in a scramble for
safety across the country's borders as
more than a million have done since the
invasion began but also huge populations
in urban centers trapped terrified
and desperate for help
civilian morale will vary now in a
population increasingly terrorized
there'll be desperation in some places
determination in others
[Music]
a spontaneous rendition of the national
anthem at that aids station in uviv
it is becoming ever clearer that the
struggle is not just for personal
survival
but for the survival of the nation as a
whole jonah al-jazeera ulviv